so schaut dass man da ist er rechts
unten so ein bild von so einem baum
solche bäume müssen wir finden dieser
komischen so einen komischen stamm so
ein dunkel dunklen ach ja und die haben
so dinger dran
und was war mit dem thema ist welches
finde das ist da dieses die casinos die
kerosin verbrennen sondern kriegst aber
das kann ich einfach zu einsammeln von
dem baum oder muster aus wir haben
geguckt ob man dafür was brauchen was
einst dann kann es einfach so nehmen ich
glaube nicht auf jeden fall ist man sich
aber triefend rate ich kenne robert
dalla batterie wo findet man roberts die
ganze aufmärschen dreht sich für uns
hauptsächlich um rabatte 0 für dieses
amt cable macht keiner weiß was da
machen grafik vrm der robert trikots in
much the same way to the top of rack
switch medi taping robert kempe vfr das
heißt die wachsen meisten hauptsächlich
über einer kleinen aber man soll diese
sachen nicht auf jeden fall nicht sofort
da wegnehmen sondern erstmal warten weil
sich das irgendwie vermehrt oder so da
irgendwie kurz warten weiß nicht ich
schaue es allerdings erst mal ganz kurz
nach weil ich hab da hinten ja man so
jung gefunden du mal nach
die schaue ich werde jetzt folgendes
machen und dann kann bob bekommen die
nicht an um ihnen das anders wir müssen
auf jeden fall diese kombination der sp
hingegen kriegen mit wie ärzte
verdoppeln können uns so ja ich gehe
eben an so einer stelle noch eben den
restlichen marmor den sand holen weil
sand und wird für unsere weil unser haus
ist auch wichtig wir können natürlich
immer sagen er macht jetzt die alte
technik sachen aber in unser haus in die
luft sprengt dann rassen wie darf ich
hab kupfer der grund ist das wichtigste
ok also doch wie kann man sich dann auf
wenn an diesem display das ist aber dann
auch ganz gut macht weil es wirklich
langweilig finden oder was neues
bis jetzt noch nicht irgendwie gedacht
so wir haben schon irgendwie was
geschafft fast gar nichts geschafft und
sind bald schon bei dem 50 er hat ist
eigentlich einerseits aber kleiner
setzte er einerseits ist es irgendwie
cool weil wir halt immer etwas anderes
haben was wir ja schon oft noch viel
arbeit vor
denken wir natürlich darauf wenigsten
sind wir eigentlich lobs oder sind wir
eigentlich low post
das ist so die franken box oder laptop
schreibt eure antwort münchen die
kommentare oder b et al a oder b pop
also überlegt euch ganz gut aber 14
beiden müsst ihr den kommentare
schreiben ist loben nochmals vitamin e
ist lobo genau wie bob und albert lauper
also könnt ihr euch einfach aussuchen
was in den conti schreibt aber ihr müsst
zeit überlegen entweder sich nach
hannover oder ja es ist nur die frage ob
man die bob ist oder halt laub oder
halten oder laub auf so außer c/o pop ja
ja ich habe ich ganz anders die gibt es
auch noch
ja
also um gespielt ist vor ich will dass
meine persönliche meinung lob also sind
den anderen halt markant und ich
verstehe dich ich finde die ganze diese
komischen bäume die sehen gar nicht so
aus wie die warte vielleicht wenn ich
jetzt normales texture pack rein packe
text rapax default bezieht ist ja alles
sehr sehr komisch aus dem man ganz kurz
vorm server runter wieder drauf jahres
steht localhost ip weil ich den haus der
ob ich habe das sind die bäume die ich
davor schon abgebaut geräumt habe ja
werden nicht einfach so kaputt machen
jetzt zusammen ist war zu kriegen wir so
noch nie zu kriegen ist aber ja aber wie
er versucht einfach ist da dran aber ich
weiß ja nicht erst einmal weiterhin wie
wir das ab und machen kann ich hab's die
core i7 das geht einfach somit ab ja ich
habe einen ein aber nur manchmal geht
das mit ab es gibt schon noch was und
das immer mehr ausziehen oder so dann
lebst du es dir durch einen kommentar
geschrieben mal macht die bitte nicht ab
weil da kriegt man später durch die
möglichkeit da ganz viel von zu fahren
oder so aber egal wir müssen diesen
beschluss müssen als auf jeden fall
zwischen okay inzwischen hat die besser
auch also guckt auf do 16 sep linke
kommst ja aber wie wartet da after
stepping die sap hall wenn ich verstehe
gar nicht existiert ist dunkel
kommen wir zum haus oder sonst wird
unser haus in die luft gesprengt ok so
ja ich komme zurück
ja keine ahnung ich schicke jetzt mal
ganz kurz so da war es auch nochmal an
da steht aber erstmal runter ins bett
gehen können rabat recycling ich habe
zwei gut können wir mal zwei pflanzen ja
gut gut gut und jetzt ab ins bett
ab ins bett mit ihr hatte ich gegen
kunstkurs vom server unter deinem per
neben ok ich kann pattinson kann hierbei
geht kurz hatte sagt wenn du warst bist
ich bin aufgewacht ist hey komm rein
con.os offen ist auf dem plastik haye
ist ein heiliges land bekommen hier habe
ich also ja ich habe zwei robert reset
setzlinge und 2 wahrte 2002 ist die
chinesen also daraus kann auf jeden fall
schon mal zwei räuber machen dann werden
wir auf jeden fall schon mal wie wir da
ran komme ich dann pflanzen uns einfach
die setzlinge die bäume hin
neben machen dann wieder die setzlinge
da kaputt weil wir haben so viel knochen
macht das keinen unterschied
richtig und da was dort gemacht ist
kaputtgegangen persönlich
nadia mich kaputt gemacht und dann
konnte sie nicht da hin setze weil er
halt keinen mama ich hab über die ganzen
wollen wir darüber und dann machen wir
uns halt ganz viele robert reid haben am
anfang erstmal ganz viel und dann kann
man es da von den ganzen sachen
mitnehmen aber dann schaust du vivier
die sticker dienst mit kriegen weil ich
habe keinen plan
leider meinte er soll irgendwie warten
wenn die weg sind oder so dann bekommt
man die video oder so aber ich weiß es
können nicht ganz genau dass es blöd ist
alles auf englisch ist also wenn ihr
irgendwas über rapper bzw
über diese ja genau es damit mit dem am
meisten den kommentaren für zuerst das
wichtigste weil du dich kriegen wie
diese ganzen chaos erlebnis gleich
wieder auch mal station eins wieder du
also wieder nächste station der nächsten
augen oder drei lassen in folge später
in drei minuten werden wir
wahrscheinlich dann eure kommentare
lesen und dann werden wir sehen ob wir
uns gut gehabt und ob a b oder c oder d
richtig ist denkt dran
jobs jobs jobs jobs so man kann keine
scheibe eines fensters ist es geht nicht
dann muss etwas anderes hin denen
entweder gesagt ich habe jetzt erstmal
zwei von diesen komischen sechs linien
hier oben kann ich keine scheibe dessen
doch jetzt geht es plötzlich was solche
seite hinten haben wir respekt steine
gar nicht einig wie sich auch
einigermaßen okay aus bedingung ist
allerdings dass sie direkt als edel aus
sogar noch mehr
aber irgendwo ist klar ich hab noch mal
so ich habe jetzt gepflanzt
guck mal wie das aussieht aber da ist
nichts dran doch da ist was dran nee das
internet das sind die sachen sind
einfach nur gelbe punkte
auch mal warten bis sie vielleicht
vielleicht kommen die daran irgendwann
ja okay stimmt dann kann man den ich
ihnen wieder dran machen egal ich habe
erstmal zwei die verbrenne ich jetzt
erstmal ganz kurz habe ich kohle habe
ich nicht mehr dass ihr dorf aus
deutschland gemacht hat ich denke wir
werden dann einfach mal bei die ganzen
kids hier sortieren wie machst du diese
stein ziegel ich nehme ganz kurz das
glashaus
ja ich hab's dicke rizinus reingepackt
brennt stein ziegel ich habe welche ich
hab drei jahre hier
danke danke haben war okay cool also wir
wissen wie wir über kriegen aber dann
wahrscheinlich nur in einer ganz ganz
ganz ganz geringen größe als quantitativ
gesehen natürlich sehr sehr minderwertig
aber jetzt noch glas für dich übrigens
by the way
ich möchte einfach mal herzlich ich weiß
nicht wer das wir da machen da liegt das
glas das einzige was wir da machen
könnten
mit schirm muss übrigens warte die tür
muss so macht das doch so warte
ich weiß nicht wie ich könnte mit dem
holz versuchen ein rapper wollte ich
mich doch hier normales fenster quellen
setzen soll also heißen naja kommt also
dann ist das doch diesem rahmen kann man
lassen
erstmals wird da würde ich da nicht so
perfekt sein aber das war es auch schon
wieder was in dem noch nicht oder ist
oder doch das war es also ich will ich
will ganz auch gucken denn jetzt eine
reihenfolge also so stark dass mit dem
holz hier ja islam wie komisch aber ich
würd ich mal sagen oder kontinent 200
können wir ein händler da könnt ihr euch
uns mit einem daumenbruch unterstützen
das zeigt uns dass es euch gefällt und
schreibt den kommentaren lernen auch
genau die war so wie wir uns verbessern
können
und weil wir sehen wir das lieber klare
aufnahme von aufnahmestation seite leute
macht natürlich folgendes ergebnis auf
jedes video von 22 bis jetzt und gleich
nochmal nachweis ich bin da könnt ihr
einen imaginären sandwich gewinnen an
gewässern von ungespielt und drauf
gerotzt von mir
lecker er leitet daran will ich sagen
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder ihr
wisst was ihr zu tun habt mit kommentare
schreiben mit rapper und so und
rotterdam ich würde sagen wir haben uns
auf jeden fall ein wenig fortentwickelt
und zwar haben wir schon diesen aires
hingekriegt naja egal da und wir haben
hier aus marmor und alles gut gegangen
und alles möglich also wenn man schon
weit entwickelt also ich also sonstig
pikachu ich bin ich schon leid tun
ich bin nicht gut an
bis zum nächsten mal hat peter pan